لقد وصلت البارحة
جيدًا يا أصدقائي الأعزاء ، من الجيد
استئناف
الاتصالات الجسدية
حتى على مسافة بعيدة ، أعتقد أنه
اجتماع مناسب جدًا لنا
لتقييم ما يجري حول
jcpoa ، فالوضع مدعاة للقلق ،
فهناك بعض التطورات الجارية
في الوقت الحالي في فيينا ،
هناك أفكار ، لذا فإن الأصدقاء الغربيين
يطوفون باللغة الروسية
في نيويورك ، وأقول أن زملائي الأعزاء من
الجيد جدًا
أن تعود إلى موسكو كورونا جعلت من
المستحيل بالنسبة لنا تتبع
عدد الزيارات التي اضطررت إلى
القيام بها  موسكو على مدى السنوات السبع الماضية ولكن
لسوء الحظ
تسبب كورونا في مقاطعة ،
أردت أن أعبر عن تعاطفنا
مع شعب روسيا
كما فعلتم معنا بشأن
عدد الضحايا لحسن الحظ ،
كان عدد الضحايا في كل من
روسيا وإيران
أقل نسبيًا
من  أماكن أخرى ولكن لا تزال
الخسائر في الأرواح احتكاكًا
بين الأفراد والعائلات ، لذلك
تعاطفنا وتضامننا مع كل من
فقدوا أحبائهم  هنا في
روسيا مذهل
من المهم بالنسبة لنا المشاركة